thank you for coming along um
to a really in-depth talk near the end
of the day um good job there was a
coffee break before this one i think
so uh yeah my name is matt warren i
sometimes blog at matt1.org
and i work at a company if it wasn't at
all obvious i
i'm happy to wear the free t-shirts they
give me i work at contrast security and
we do
security tools for developers and part
of why and this interests me because it
overlaps with my day job and some of the
things i get to do there which i'll go
into a little bit later but generally we
provide
tools for you to analyze your code and
see if there's security issues that's
what contrast is about but this talk is
about performance in the dot net runtime
uh i should start with
uh i guess a disclaimer up front i i
love this stuff around net internals
if it wasn't clear if you read anything
on my blog i
more than happy to spend quite a lot of
time figuring this stuff out just mostly
for the fun of it some of it as i said
overlaps my day job but um a lot of this
is for information and it's been quite
good over the last few years because
basically they
opensourced.net runtime back in 2016.
um so
we can dive into this stuff you can get
you know if you if you're really keen
and you really want to you can build
your own version of the runtime and run
it locally in debug mode just for the
fun of it um but uh more seriously is
that we can find this stuff out it's a
lot easier i'm trying to do some of the
things i do to research talks like this
and others um 10 years ago would have
required some sort of ninja win dbg
skills and
a level of assembly that's beyond me but
i really like this stuff and i really
enjoy digging into it and sounds seems
like people
respond to that as well but i think it's
um
easy to say you know i like this stuff
but maybe put my money where my mouth is
this is my collection of books as far as
i know i've got every one of every book
that ever come out that talks anything
about the.net runtime internals and
there's a few that aren't here that i
have ebooks i some point
start to stop collecting physical books
um but anyway this is quite a good set
of resources if you want to know more
about um often it overlaps with
performance actually so some of the
books are writing about talking about
getting performance but
mentioned so this is a good list the one
that's missing here in my recent one i'm
reading is a the thousand page book
about product it's called pro.net memory
management if you want to learn anything
about the net gc um it's covered in that
one thousand page book but anyway
there's a lot of good resources out
there as well as blogs um so yeah i
really i really like this stuff um but
maybe a bit more of an a um
justification for this
it's not just because i like talking
about it and hopefully other people like
uh
listening to it as well but actually um
there's a level where understanding one
level below what we're working from is
useful
so it quite often comes up in
performance if you want to get the most
performance at the clr um the runtime
you do need to have an idea of what the
jit is doing or the garbage collector is
doing you need to understand
which things are more costly than others
uh you also need to measure and all the
other sort of general advice this is not
a performance talk in that sort of way
but you know you need to measure these
things but actually there's times isn't
it i'm not going to stand here and claim
that day in day out knowing what's going
on in the run time is affecting our jobs
that would be a bit disingenuous but i
think for a lot of us there's times
where this stuff comes up
um you know i think also it's it's um
good that uh as a kind of wider
community it's not just the people at
microsoft who work on the runtime that
know these things i think it's good that
actually it helps our ecosystem it helps
us have better
libraries on.net or it helps this
general understanding of what the
runtime does um the promise of the run
time is that we can treat it as a black
box and yes that does apply we just
write r c sharp
f sharp vb.net code whatever language
we're writing and then the runtime does
its thing but actually there's
times when it's worth knowing one level
below your usual abstraction
and of course that that can vary so
sometimes that usual abstraction is you
know you're working on top of asp.net so
you need to know that sometimes it's the
base class library but i believe i think
for a lot of us there's times we're
actually knowing things about the
runtime how is uh
how how delegates work or why certain
types of method calls are more expensive
than others and as i said before it
often comes up with performance to get
the highest performance out of the
runtime
knowing these things is useful
so there's a lot of things in the
runtime to give a bit of
scope to that i did a previous talk
which was called from.net run to hello
world the simplest program you can do
that's a 45 minute talk just talking
about everything that happens from the
point you write dot net run to the point
that hello world appears on the screen
and that if you know anything about
those sorts of applications a very small
application misses out a lot of the
stuff that the runtime does there's
probably no time for a gc to happen and
a few other things i've deliberately
missed out so there's a lot going on in
the run time it's a huge
piece of engineering it's a huge piece
of software there's a lot of stuff going
on there so to give a bit of focus i'm
just trying to do the overlap the
intersection of some things that are
going on in the runtime
that are designed or written or
implemented in a way that give us
performance so we get to use the runtime
we write our code
and there's a lot of things that
actually happen to not just a naive way
there's a lot of work that's gone in to
make things that we would expect to be
fair from a runtime to be quick but
there's a lot of work to make that
happen and we'll talk about those one of
the ones is maybe methods calls we don't
ever really think about what's going on
with them ethical that's fair enough the
runtime handles that for us but it's not
an accident that nets can
work in high performance situations
taking power and things like if you've
ever seen those benchmarks and a lot of
work goes into making even something as
simple as a method called efficient
so um but just to give a kind of um
overview of the landscape if you like i
know that not everyone has
been delved into the code of the runtime
or knows some of the components from
that so
this is probably i think
about well i think it's pre-covered so
anyway that makes it a couple of years
old so you could probably add 10 or 20
to these numbers but it gives you an
idea right there's a lot of code in
there over 2 million lines of
source code 8 million lines of test code
which is i think it's not a bad ratio
for a runtime you'd hope that they'd be
testing quite well
this is what's considered the core
runtime the base class libraries are
separate from this so you can these
numbers go up if you start to include
all the you know the base class
libraries we know and use every day the
the collections and all the other things
that live in system and microsoft name
spaces is the core runtime can actually
run standalone
can't do too much more than just a
hallowed app with the core runtime you
do need the base class libraries to do
anything more useful but this gives you
an idea of the scope of that lots of
files of source code there's quite a lot
of c-sharp code in there although a lot
of that is test code and by far the bulk
of the runtime is written in
c plus which may not be that surprising
quite a lot of il code that's generally
for testing the runtime wants to be able
to
test in different scenarios without
necessarily having to rely on the
company so it has its own you know it
goes directly from the il code because
that's at the level the runtime works we
write our c-sharp f-sharp whatever code
that gets turned into il and the runtime
then does the job on the il code a bunch
of assembler code and we'll look at some
of that later on a bit of python and
perl i believe is for scripting and
test you know
supporting code i don't think any of
that none of that ends up in the runtime
itself but the point i want to get
across is there's a serious amount i've
gone into this and the open source uh
corsillar is mostly known although it's
now that they changed it you know.net
five just became.net not rather than.net
core but anyway that runtime has not
suddenly appeared as an open source
version that's come from the heritage of
net all the way back to the beginning
through silverlight and all the
different versions so it's not just code
that suddenly appeared uh what 2016 uh
six years ago um it's built on all the
code in fact some of the code um goes
way back to the very beginning some of
the low-level internal things uh don't
change um they might have uh improved
certain parts but there's parts you can
trace back and one of the books i showed
a minute ago is about something called
rota and roads was essentially the
runtime that was open sourced about 20
years ago it was under a sort of
academic license and it roughly equates
to the net 2 time frame and you can look
at the source code of rota and you can
see some similarity at least in the file
names maybe not completely the content
of the file but there's things that have
stuck around since that point
maybe a
more pictorial way of looking at things
these are just
um square maps just basically the size
of the source code in those folders and
these folders are not just the source
code folders on disk but they're kind of
the naming terminology of those
components as well um so it's fairly
well structured and split up like that
so to go through some of these
mscorelib is actually now system private
call it this is the c-sharp code in the
runtime and this is things like
system.gc
there's a rule about this part of the
code that it can't have any dependencies
so anything this code needs to run has
to be in there so that's why some
collections are in there obviously the
core type string and
some of those are implemented in there
and this is and then reflection is
another one that sits in there so it's
kind of very core parts of the component
that the bits that are needed
uh to do anything at all and the bare
minimum if you like
but the reason why um
that sits in the run time and not
separately is because
that uh say you take an example of
system.gc right the apis in system.gc
need to match exactly what the current
version of the gc is doing so that's why
this um is shipped as part of the
runtime not as a as a separate thing and
there's some special rules like i said
it has to be the first
thing loaded it can't and certain types
um strings and arrays as we can sort of
imagine are quite special types they do
quite special things so the runtime
needs to know that the code in here is
matching what the runtime is certain
things that this can do that other codes
sorry in terms of knowledge this code
hack might have that other third party
or even base class libraries can't have
that same knowledge
um the jit just in time compiler is a
huge chunk as well
um the code that's responsible for
taking the il that's come from the
compiler the c-sharp compiler roslin
compiler
and then uh jitting it the first time
it's run that has to worry about
generally different cpu architectures
you know it's jitting code for all the
platforms that um
net runs on so uh
x86 x64 arm 64
and some other ones i've gotten anyway
there's quite a few and they're growing
over time
and so there's obviously per cpu
architecture
knowledge in there there's you know
functions are written multiple times to
support different things it has to have
a knowledge of registers and lots of
things there's a lot of complexity in
there
the gc is a
relatively standalone component as well
there is actually a way you can run the
gc if you're really keen you can run the
gc separate from the runtime
and also in theory you could implement
your own gc and drop it in as a
replacement as an api and an interface
it sits behind probably the most thing
people know the most interesting thing
about the gc is there's a is basically
one single file gc.cpp and for the
longest time if you looked on github at
the file it would say too big to too big
to render um so there's historical
reasons
they maybe they like the idea it's one
file who knows i wouldn't fancy working
on a 35 000 line of code and file but
anyway that's the way it is and it's
probably not going to change it's being
part of the run time from the beginning
um another bit that's always surprises
me is just how much goes into debugging
so if you're in
tess's talk this morning talking about
debugging she showed wind ebg
and sos right sos is the
component if you want to do anything
debugging.net
memory dumps or net code in wind dbg you
need to use sos you load it up and it
has the commands and along with the
other components really that provides
the bridge so ndbg is like a native
debugger
it only knows about native codes our
code in the runtime is managed it's gone
through legit there's kind of levels of
abstraction on there in native code
there's data structures that describe
and all sorts of stuff so
that's the job of sos is kind of like a
plug-in but also you have the
dia data access that's providing a way
for given a dot-net process how do i get
useful information out of it like
where's the location in memory where i
can find the list of all the threads
that are running because they're managed
threads not native threads how can i
find information about a jitted method
how can i find information about
managed types all these sorts of things
that's
data access layers provided there on top
of that
when you're debugging say in visual
studio you know you're doing f9 f10
whatever all that sort of stuff and
that's talking to the.net debugging api
again
visual studio understands native but to
control a.net process to be able to step
through even something as simple as
stepping through lines you know when
you're stepping through the actual
assembly you need to map that back
via the il to the original code that was
written you need to understand that
relationship because we don't want to
step through in terms of assembly code
we want to step through in terms of our
high-level c-sharp code which is not
necessarily a one-to-one mapping of
assembly
so there's quite a lot going on there
platform adaption layer is so that the
runtime can affect program regardless of
the os and then this part of the code
handles that's the theory behind the
platform adaption layer so obviously for
the longest time.net pretty much ran on
windows but you know now it's linux and
there's code in there to let it run on
unix and all the different os's it
supports
and then onto the um apis you might not
know that the runtime actually has api
so i sort of talked about one already
there's a debugging api that's how any
third party and visual studio debugger
can talk can debug a dot-net process as
a there's an api to use it's uh
into process communication there's
commands sent back from forwards you
know you move to the next breakpoint all
these sorts of things there's an api
that allows it to do that
and third-party third-party debuggers
these are published apis up on msdn docs
it's known as i-core debug the debugging
api and then icore profiler is the
profiling api and essentially my day job
is working with the icor profiler api
and it's what probably most people know
if you've used any profiling tools
obviously but
any apm tools um
net apm tools will probably use the
profiling api
it gives you the sort of access to a
runtime process that those tools need
and one of the main bits that a lot of
those tools do and what certainly the
tool i work on does is actually rewrite
your il at runtime that's sort of the
secret
code of some of those tools that's how
those tools can instrument your code
without you having to make changes and
that's part of what the profiling api
provides
so just as a sort of um
little tip if you ever think okay i'd
really like a job where some of this
internals and this runtime stuff is like
part of my daily job if you ever see a
job advert asking for knowledge or
mentioning the profiling api or
debugging api that's probably your sort
of um secret way in right it's worked
for me for the past six years you
certainly have to understand um yeah one
terms of one level of interaction lower
to to work with the profiling apis but
just to give a caveat those apis are com
apis and you're writing code in c plus
plus so if that's
that's not your thing um so my job is
split between
the code and writing in profiling which
is c plus at the same time writing a
managed part of well it's a bit of both
but um certainly those apis require
knowledge and if com is a word that you
don't ever want to hear in your
professional life then then maybe stay
away from that but anyway there's some
apis in there and um
fortunately and i think uh microsoft is
not a coincidence they these are all
versioned apis microsoft agrees to
support them it's why there's a big
ecosystem of third-party tools
in in situations where microsoft doesn't
necessarily want to make all those tools
they've made these apis available and
they support them throughout all the
different versions of net
onto the part that is the most focus of
of this talk today is that is sometimes
known as the vm virtual machine that's
the folder it's stored in sometimes
known as the execution engine it's it's
it's really the bit that hangs all the
other parts together it's the bit that
executes first and then it will invoke
the jit it's the bit that sets up the gc
and and gets that running and the other
parts are clearly not trivial but the
the there's a lot of work going in in
the virtual machine side of the code is
what's considered i suppose the runtime
part of it
but what sort of things it do well quite
a lot so you've got your type system in
there generics um we pretty much take
generics for granted right we've been
fortunate.net to have them since dot net
two so only if you're in the very early
versions of dot net would you have not
had generics and
maybe you remember arraylist and all the
you know the non-generic things but
anyways we we can write generic code
maybe if you've seen other runtimes like
go it took a while for them to get
uh generics and there's big debates
about how they can make it work with the
language so we should be quite grateful
that it's been in if we like using or
writing generic code we should be
grateful it's been in.net but it
basically makes everything else harder
your types have to be aware of generics
because types can be genetics methods
have to be aware of genetics method
calls are more complicated if you're
calling a method with generic arguments
and so on and so on um so
the type system is uh also important
because it's what gives us type safety
and if we didn't have type safety
i guess we'd be writing you know dynamic
code and if you've ever done any dynamic
code you know the trade-offs there right
we can rely on quite a lot of things in
c sharp in terms of if our code compiles
we know something about it
obviously the built-in types they have
to ship with the runtime so strings
arrays all the primitives those sorts of
things span nowadays is another one
that's added in there span read only
memory
included in that loading types and
classes generally are types and classes
loading as well but obviously any other
code has to deal with that and as again
the guarantees it won't load a type that
doesn't meet the type system
requirements if you've ever had type
load exceptions or those sorts of things
you know there is ways
not generally in writing in c sharp code
that goes through a compiler but if you
ever you know you can write whatever il
you want and pass it to the run time and
it'll have a go at it so it has to be
sure that it knows the classes fit in
with type safety
threading we obviously have threading we
don't probably nowadays aren't really
writing you know newing up threads and
stuff there's thread pulls and much
higher levels of abstraction but they're
all built on top of the threads that the
runtime provides that aren't os threads
so there's a whole level of abstraction
there
exception handling stack walking again i
mean we probably don't like getting
exceptions in our code but if you ever
used a language or runtime it doesn't
give you decent stack traces or doesn't
tell you you know where exception
happened you should be very grateful
that you know with the first class
experience we have in visual studio that
pops up an exception and gives us the
whole stack trace and we can you know
jump to different parts of the stack
trace we can see
variables in the stack trace we can you
know all these sorts of things the
runtime provides quite a lot of that and
just the whole exception handling and
the ability to throw and catch and all
those sorts of things
we probably use quite often in our code
uh event tracing profiling i've talked a
bit about um but event tracing is quite
a lot so if you again the talk this
morning talked about tools like dot net
counters or dot net collectors a lot of
these tools are querying into the
runtime and finding this information out
there's a lot of
information the runtime publishes about
itself of what it's doing
and just even something like p invoke
right we i mean maybe we're not using it
directly but it's there in almost
everything we do um calling out to
native codes maybe from time to time we
use it directly and put the dll import
and stuff there's quite a lot of work
there
so that gives us a rough idea of the
landscape so the first thing i'm going
to talk about is virtual stub dispatch
has anyone heard of this in the context
of
of.net
a few people great so everyone else is
going to learn something new today so
virtual stub dispatch is um you will
know it you just won't know it's maybe
called that but let's say um so hands up
who's got an eye logger interface in
their code
yeah okay and hands up who's got any
interfaces in their code
that's everyone right i don't think many
people write any code but without
interfaces so we kind of take it for
granted right we can do interfaces the
whole program to the abstraction not the
implementation we can switch out
although actually we probably find that
a lot of the time you might only have
one implementation of an interface
because it makes it mockable and
testable and all those other things as
well so it's not even we're always
having multiple implementations but
that's there as well so you have the
kind of standard thing you have a i
logger this is a console one you can
imagine like a
azure
table storage logger or whatever event
log logger there's different
implementations you might swap it out by
di or have your code set up
but it's called virtual because actually
in the il uh actually this is more than
metadata if you were to look in the
iel spy or some of those tools ieldas
and they'll often put in the
at least the one i was using here puts
the um
method attributes uh as comments so this
is not saying we see in our code but
this is what's behind the scene in the
metadata and it's talking about virtual
um and then uh so i like to think of
virtuals like essentially it's because
the compiler can't
guarantee where that method call is
going to live at compile time because
it's behind an interface you have a
method it's given an ilogger interface
now you could say it could analyze the
whole program and see okay there's only
one concrete implementation so it must
end up there yeah that is true but the
dot net just in time compiler doesn't
generally do that it looks at just
methods because that's quite expensive
to analyze the whole program and even if
it could analyze the whole program
actually you can dynamically load types
so there's nothing to stop you doing
plugins and assembly load from and all
that sort of stuff to load another
implementation of the interface so
essentially it means certainly at
compile time and generally even at
startup time it can't guarantee
except in a few niche cases where that
method so by the time the runtime
executes a method it doesn't really care
about interfaces now it needs to know
the place in memory where the code for
that method is and it needs to be able
to go there having put the parameters on
the stack or whatever the stuff it does
before it needs to basically jump to
that location and that code needs to
execute does what it does and then jump
back and return values and all the
things it does in a method call
so it needs to have a concrete thing and
that's what virtual's all about
so if we look at this example here we've
got an eye logger method
so in the the one that isn't highlighted
it's taking a concrete implementation
the compiler can figure all that out it
knows it's a console logger class it can
say right you just need to call the
console logger class
log error method that's fine there's no
issues there but if we're talking about
a method with a interface it needs to
know which implementation of the log
error function that ends up as
this is a slightly confusing example
because actually
when you knew up a class and then
straightaway caller method that's saying
legit can figure out because you've
literally just created the object so
it's smart enough to do that so it can
do some and that's something called d
virtualization that we'll get onto a
minute but generally when it's looking
at the something went wrong method at
the bottom highlighted it doesn't know
until the method's called at runtime
what
where it needs to
jump to to actually execute that method
and so you see that in il if you dig
down to that it uses the cool vert
instruction it actually uses the cool
vert in the concrete case because the
culvert also does null checking if
you've ever looked at that so it's sort
of a safety thing because the cool verts
there's actually a cool instruction that
can be more efficient but it doesn't
check for nulls but certainly in the
case we're looking at here it's covert
so that's why it's virtual it doesn't
know at compile time
um
but something else we need to understand
about this is whenever you call them
sorry not whenever in most situations
you call a method in.net between the
call sites where you you know you write
foo and pass in the parameters and the
callee where the method actually
executes
there's generally a stub
and stubs are like everywhere in the
runtime if you want proof that blog post
is 11 000 words i wouldn't recommend
reading it all in one go there's a table
of contents but it shows all the places
p and vote goes through stubs there's
stubs that handle moving from managed to
native code and marshalling and a few
other things there's stubs when you call
generic methods because it needs to
know about generic arguments because
uh we'll do generics in a minute but
there's stubs in a lot of places and so
i think of stubs as like a bit of
housekeeping a bit of fix up is not two
method calls this is all one method
called the stub in the middle is like
doing a bit of work moving a few things
around and then a straight jump
literally a jump assembly instruction to
the place and it does some fix up
so that's what's going on with stubs
so this person simon hall
i came across his name because there's
something called the book of the run
time and if you want to get into
the dot net runtime and you want a free
results i showed some books earlier but
on the github repository botr book of
the run time is under their docs folder
it is um
written
for runtime engineers by runtime
engineers so it's not an introductory
thing i often read one of these pages
uh scratch my head a bit
make a few notes come back a week later
and then understand a little bit more
and read it you know so it's not that
they're uh not well written there's not
there's not nice diagrams but they are
written with an assumption that you're
already working on the runtime and
here's how another bit of the runtime
works so it's a bit of knowledge maybe
to get into them i've got some good
mileage out of basically uh
understanding enough about a book of the
runtime page to feel i can write a blog
post to explain it to people who don't
want to read the book of the runtime
page so anyway but uh he wrote the page
on virtual stub dispatch and he was so
pleased with what he did he put on his
linkedin i mean you would because
virtual desktop dispatches every time a
method or maybe not every time i think
something they've done some stats in in
some measurements elsewhere 95 of
methods when we call a method involving
an interface go through virtual stub
dispatchers a few times that it can go
directly but
so in the dot net 2 time frame they did
they redesigned it and this is the sort
of stuff that the runtime engineers have
to worry about right so there's a
trade-off performance but also memory
locality memory density if they had
something that made all our code run
faster but every time the.net app
started up it used twice as much memory
then we'd probably be a bit annoyed
right so they have to do these
trade-offs and um we'll come on as a
second the stubs of small because they
don't want to make a have a bad
trade-off in terms of memory um but they
did um improve it so anyway yeah if i'd
if i'd done saying a significant that
i'd be putting it on my linkedin that's
for sure and you look at the other stuff
you you did quite a lot of
interesting bits on the net runtime
probably uh yeah ten years or so again
um
so virtual stub dispatch the way it
works is step by step is this uh first
time it comes in it's basically that i
don't know right it doesn't know where
that method exists the concrete method
it knows the object you're calling it
again so it can do some lookups
because the runtime has something called
a method table attached just in front of
every object on the heap there's a
pointer to the method table and the
method table is basically
which type uh class or struts or
whatever this object is off and that's
why we um have well one of the things it
enables is reflection the strong
you know the
really rich reflection that we get in
dot net but it also helps with type
safety and a few other things but that's
a an overheads that that's why um we
talk about say we get into classes
versus struts
every class instant object engine sorry
on the heap has that overhead because it
needs to be able to reference back from
the actual data of the object to say
which type is this and that obviously
also helps with things like when the
runtime's doing um
class hierarchies to know whether which
methods are called in the hierarchy if
you've overridden your inheritance and
it also helps with um method sorry
interface
so the first time is like i don't know
so it has to fall back to
step four in this case
which is basically
go and find out where this method lives
i've got an object
i know the method of the interface
and remember that
an object has its own methods a class
sorry a type has its own methods plus
the ones that is implemented for the
interface you can have multiple
interfaces implemented to the class you
can explicitly implement interface
methods and you can have methods that
just exist on your type that aren't
anything to do with the interface so it
has to figure all that out then you
throw in you know does this class
override a base class and these are
abstract classes and there's a bit of
stuff to calculate there
once it knows that it starts to build up
the stub
and there's an assumption it makes
basically there's a high chance that
next time you call the same method
you might call it with the same type of
object not the same instance but the
same type so that's the monomorphic case
one
i'm going to assume that and i believe
they've done some analysis of programs
and some other things to say that's kind
of common and it goes back to what we
said in the beginning we might implement
an interface just for the sake of having
that abstraction so we can make it union
testable in our production code there
might only be one
instant concrete implementation of that
class running there might be a two if
you're looking at the test code but so
that's why that
it's kind of let's optimize for the best
case scenario which is there's one
implementation and it's the same one i
saw last time
but we know that's not true right all
the time so it has to have a fullback so
it then has to fall back to the
polymorphic right there's two
implementations this interface i need to
look at the object every time and decide
which one of those two it is and
dispatch to the right place
and um
and one thing worth pointing out in
generic zelda it did sign called back
patching so that the first time it comes
in it goes to the resolver straight down
to four but next time it doesn't want to
do that so back patches which is like
rewriting some location of code in
memory
to set the um
object so that next time it can say
right is this the same object it does a
comparison
another way of looking at if you want
and this is from the book of the
runtime is uh
this is a different path because it can
change and it can actually say look i
made a guess the first time based on the
fact i thought you'd always call it with
this
concrete implementation but you know
what in the 99 times since then you've
called it a different one i think i
better adjust my best guess because i'm
always falling back to the you know the
worst case scenario so it's these things
are changing and then it will redo the
back patching to have you know but it
doesn't want to get in a case where it's
always back patching you know so there's
a bit more logic there because you could
get in a bad case where it's always
swapping between two or things like that
so again these are things they need to
worry about because it wouldn't be great
if our method was quick the first time
but every subsequent time it was slow so
these things have to adapt
and in fact in the debug version of the
runtime you can turn on some stats and
they're able to run a program and see
things like effectively cache hits and
misses how many times am i going through
the happy the best case path how many
times am i falling back how many times
am i changing my guess and repatching
and so on and this again is all back to
the simon the guy i showed previously
his page this was all different in dot
net one and they updated it in dot net
two um for performance
and part of actually the other thing
they did is you can um have two cool
sites and they can go through two
different stubs even though they end up
the same page because basically they
determined that the call sites could be
calling the same method but with
different usage patterns
so again this was like a this was a
trade-off they said right we'll have
more stubs
we'll keep them small we'll have more
stubs but it gives better throughput
i'm not going to show a lot of assembly
codes because i can't understand it all
let's be clear but i can at least
understand this so this is the kind of
monomorphic case what it's doing is a
comparison of the eax which is like the
uh point of the current object comparing
it to expected this is like i've seen
this before
are you the same type i saw last time
if you're not jump to the failure case
the the worst case i need to adjust my
logic or i need to fall back to
something else
if you are what i expect because i've
seen you before then jump straight to
the target so we see that actually it's
two assembly instructions they've got it
down to two assembly instructions for
the best case scenario
and again this is the sort of stuff that
the runtime engineers have to worry
about if that was too big and we had
lots of these stubs in memory and that
you know you can imagine how many places
in our code we call different cool sites
calling different um methods
a lot basically
um but this is all overhead so they
would like to get rid of it so that's
the opposite of all this is
de-virtualization and if the jit can
actually say do you know what i don't
need to do any of this it can save the
two extra even in the best cases
instructions
it's part of it is also it's not just
the best case but like the the first
time through when i said it has to fall
back that's slow so that first time
through equals slower startup so that's
why this is also important so there's
been some work uh this is from a little
while ago yeah back in 2017. i think
this issue is still open
they're trying to say is there more and
more situations we can skip all this out
it's a great mechanism they've
tuned it over time it's about as
efficient as it could be when you're
talking two assembly instructions but
you know what code would be even faster
and this is when we get into like
checking power running at you know
million frames a second uh sorry a
million uh 10 million requests per
second in front um that sort of level
right this thing starts to matter more
so sometimes
some places may not use interfaces
because there is a cost overhead you
have to time it to prove it's really a
difference for your situation but there
is a
cost overhead for interfaces
so we've covered that so value types
i'm sure these are familiar to most
people who's ever had uh an interview
where you've been asked about struts
versus classes right it's pretty yeah i
think it's hard it feels like hard to
get a net job at some point in your crew
or you don't get asked that and there's
a whole thing about do they live on the
heat they live on the stack whatever you
know people you know you
read read it on stack overflow get the
answer next time you have a job
interview but um
the point more is about what they're
implemented so the things that we do
know about struts and versus classes
is there's no method table overhead for
a strut so they compact more in memory
and that's one of the main reasons
people end up using them because
the the data needed for a structure is
just the data for the fields of that
strut
i think it's one thing in terms of like
taking stuff for granted right we
changed the struct keyword the class
keyword destruct right it's one one word
change there's quite a lot of stuff that
that implications for the runtime is
quite big behind the scenes
um so yeah if you had an array of um
struts the data in the ray would be
literally struts zero structure one
packed in there
the fields of that within that
if you have an array of classes what
you've got is an array of references
that point to the the actual reference
living somewhere else
they might be all near each other if you
allocate them together they could be all
over the gc can move things around
compact whatever but it's still that
extra level of indirection that
reference to go from what's in the array
which is a
it does mean that reference is easier to
handle in some ways because a reference
is always the same size because it's a
pointer to somewhere else but struts
give us if you care about packing things
in memory if you care about the
efficiency of not having that extra
level of indirection that's why i think
in games and things like that or you go
and look in the
kestrel source code
that's what's running um in the tech and
power benchmarks that that sort of thing
becomes more of an issue
and there's also the discussion around
allocation and you know it causes gc
generally struts uh can be allocated on
the stack except well they aren't going
to go into that whole thing as i said
look it up stack overflow but
you can a lot of time assume that they
are allocated on the stack which equals
no gc no gc pauses
but as i said we take it for granted uh
so i counted a while back because
there's 63 places in the run times no
64. 64 places in the runtime and 23
issues also i don't know um where they
where the code has the runtime code has
to care whether the of the type sorry
that it's dealing with is a is a value
type or is a
struct or is a reference type
and a lot of that um you can see
something like um
reflection invocation of class there but
a lot of that is the first case which is
boxing right boxing is one of the things
it has to worry about once you get into
value types because you can box value
types into an object and it has to deal
with that and that's what the runtime
helps us out with
but another place is
when you're calling a method you're
calling a method with
reference it's when the word comes in
right by reference you're passing a
reference to an object
that reference is always the same size
on 32-bit or 64-bit you just pass in
effect to pointer and then the method
that on the other call site sorry the
callee on the other end just takes that
reference and then can access the type
struts passed by value it needs to
physically put the contents of the strut
and at this level we're talking about
on the stack or as an optimization
registers so there's a certain amount of
registers it varies again per cpu
there's rules about registers some
registers are reserved so you see in the
top case here and i haven't got the
laser but you see in the top left here
uh this parameter
so that's passed around as like an
implicit parameter so we call a method
we don't ever pass this parameter but if
we're calling an instance method on a
class that's done for us behind the
scenes
um
the reason in this case uh if you
haven't picked it up yet what's
happening is all the arguments are being
shuffled one left so this pointer is
being dropped and it's shuffled one left
if you want to find out what's going on
there you can read the issue it's one of
my favorite things i've discovered it's
called a gener a shuffle thunk and its
job is to move everything that way
because by the time the method is called
this argument needs to not be there and
it's it's to do with delegates and i'm
not going to go into oh if you're not
come and ask me later i can explain a
bit more but the point is um this is the
stuff it has to deal with and it would
like to put as much possible in uh we've
highlighted it green right that's
registers registers are fast and stack
so when it gets down to moving stuff
around if it can reuse registers great
but there's rules about which registers
can be used certain data types only
fitted certain registers you have
special purpose registers they're
different on x86 versus x64 you also
have to respect the platform or os
running on them because there's some
rules about registers and um saying
that's known as abi application binary
interface which is how do methods get
called on this platform so that's
different on windows versus linux even
under x86 so complexity all over the
place um but yeah just to give you a
sort of uh idea so it's shuffling these
things around because um
when you go from a
cool site to a callee
the callee of that method expects things
to be in a certain place it needs to
know the rules of where it can get the
parameters for that method it knows what
type of method it is it knows it's got
you know
three arguments
um but it's a job of the call site to
put things in the right registers if
it's a very you know these things are uh
sort of um laid out in in something
called api's application binary
interfaces
another thing about generics this might
be a bit more known but if you have a
generic method simplest one possible
literally storing a value it's a wrapper
right we've got one field of type t
we've got a store method where we pass
in t and it stores it right
it seems a bit contrived but i'll show
in a minute there's actually real world
examples for this
the point is is if t is a reference type
it does um sharing right it can
basically say
all reference types are in terms of what
i need to worry about are the same size
so i can i know the location i can store
them in the same location i don't care
whether it's
your own class or a base class library
class if it's a reference type easy so
it does shared and that's to stop there
being an explosion of methods if it did
a different method for every
time we you know so we have like
i list right that's generic if every
time we need upper lists for a different
type you know so the runtime cares
enough to make sure there's not a lot of
extra methods and it can do that by
sharing all the method implementations
at the assembly code level for
reference types it can't do the same for
value types so this is primitives
same applies if it was our own struts
so that's because partly it's because
they're different sizes so an int is
different size and a double so it can't
make assumptions about even something as
simple as storing a value because they
need to be stored differently because
they have different physical sizes even
if they're the same size we sort of see
a bit here there's different assembly
instructions that make sense so this is
like a vectorized version the bottom
right can store the double more
efficiently
legit cares about this because we want
our code to be as fast as possible with
some of the stuff the jit does for us we
don't probably think about it right i
just want to put whatever i want in a
list but actually the jit students work
to make the double version as efficient
as it could be for doubles versus the
version for floats versus for ins
um but it does mean it has to create
different versions so this is you know
there'd be two different versions of
this store method for both these cases
why this is important because actually
you can kind of use it as a trick and i
suppose some people have heard of ben
adams right people heard of um
if you want to learn about some really
good performance tricks look up
ben adams github profile and see some of
the pr's he's done in the kestrel web
server like this one here
in asp.net sometimes in the runtime
it's fair to say you know he's what he's
talking about with performance and he's
submitted many many pr's and quite a lot
of them have what helped push the tech
in power uh up if you've seen the taking
power results they publish from time to
time showing.net
basically.net competing with others i
think it's kind of it's one of those
ones that's at the level of they're
maxing out the network card right
they're all there's a few that are sort
of all within a kind of space for each
other it shows that actually uh you know
maybe we're not writing code that needs
to run at 10 million requests per second
but it's quite nice to know that we're
working on a run time that could be used
for that if we'd ever need to
um but he uses this thing
david fallon for many people know calls
it type system abuse
he likes to call it working with type
systems you can actually use this trick
of the
uh legit having to make a different
version of every generic method you can
use it to get more efficient code
um and he did that so he literally is
very similar to the code of wrote a few
slides back he wrapped a frame in a
strut frame adapter that pretty much you
can see stores the frame and then passes
through the methods to
and then obviously wrapped it when you
do it and this 39 000 extra requests per
second and the reason it can do that
going back to the previous slide showing
ins versus doubles is for every
different struct it sees legit makes a
different method and because it makes a
different method you can optimize it
just for that code so that can be the
most efficient version so we saw the one
of ins and doubles it was making them
more efficient based on that there's
other stuff the jit can do but it can
specialize because it's not making a
kind of generic generic method if that
makes sense
with struts i'm not saying wrap every
class in your codes with a struts please
don't do that um as you can see i mean
it's it's a nice number but it's it was
already at one million requests per
second one point yeah one 121 thousand
it went up to one million you know we're
talking quite a you need to be at quite
a high level performance before this
really helps um but anyway it's part of
what um
uh the runtime provides has given us
this flexibility because not all
runtimes has the ability of value types
right not going to start naming names
but there is some that don't let you
create your own value types or are still
trying to get that in their runtime so
it's quite nice that net
clr gives us this option if we need it
having said all that
they want to have universal share
generics because obviously there's a
cost for all of this for the runtime and
they'd like to make
the ability to have more generic methods
because we don't always need that extra
performance and so um yeah there's an
idea it's again this is from a little
while ago me basically asking what
you're talking about what is universal
share generics but the idea is that
actually
there's a cost and the reason it matters
more is because of ahead of time
compilation
this specialized version of the code has
to be jitted at runtime that doesn't
help so when you want to have generics
and ahead of time compilation as i said
generics makes everything harder in the
runtime this is the sort of thing they
might need to go down the route of
having not having specialized even
though it gives a nice performance boost
in some cases i think that ultimately
for ahead of time compilation that's you
can see why mono's had it there for a
little while as well
and it plays a part
okay so on to another thing of value
type so boxing so we generally say
boxing is uh is is bad right you want to
avoid if possible you don't want to
always be boxing your
struts into an object
but but even in that case the runtime
tries to make it as efficient as
possible and clearly those more objects
go on the heap and the garbage collector
has to do more work but the garbage
collector is a pretty impressive bit of
code and there's you know it's not like
all garbage collection is slow and
pauses your application is many times it
can clean up huge amounts of memory on
the heap without your program you know
beating her having a beat or whatever
so uh even for saying like boxing which
is considered you shouldn't be doing it
excessively they at least try to make it
as efficient as it could be so it'll try
and
try and inlining in lining is like the
first thing the jit does because if you
can inline a method into the cooling
method then it's just more efficient
because you haven't even got the
mechanism of a method call and it can
then do other optimizations after that
but it generally only does that for
things it knows about in 64's primitive
types
so there's an assembly helper so one of
the things you see quite a lot in the
runtime is
handwritten assembly code
because if you think right so the
options for the runtime is write it in c
plus plus so that's okay you can you can
rely but then you're relying on the
compiler doing the right thing
you could write a lot of runtime code in
manage code and then you need the jit to
jit it
but the jit isn't necessarily uh
thinking too much about jitting the sort
of code that exists in the run time it's
more worried about jitting the code
wheel right and making that efficient
and certainly when they were first
making the runtime they're making it at
the same time as the jit was being made
so there wasn't you know so it's kind of
chicken and egg thing so there's times
where there's handwritten bits of
assembly um just because it's very
specific what they want to do or because
it's performance or because they can't
write it any other way because it won't
do the most performant code and then it
falls back to some c plus plus code so
again there's a sort of idea a lot of
the time to run time like a fast path
there's many times that the uh code can
allocate without needing uh
to trigger a um garbage collection if uh
you're in any gc tool called certainly
talked about this one is an idea of
segments and if there's space in the
current segment uh allocation is really
just bumping a pointer to make space for
the object it's only when it runs out of
space in the segment then the gc has to
get involved and decide whether to
allocate more segments or do a garbage
collection and so on so a lot of the
time allocation uh
not really allocation it's just bumping
a pointer
sometimes it can fall back to those to
give an idea of some of this code um
[Music]
essentially uh is copying via pointer um
if you've ever done any c plus plus this
is like you know the sort of stuff you
have to write in c
but it's basically
if it can if it's a certain size so one
two four or eight it will just literally
copy so we're talking about here you've
got your struts and you've just ended up
being boxed and it needs to create a
chunk of memory on the heap and put the
contents of that strut into the if you
like into the box
i guess that's where the name comes from
um so it needs to copy the contents of
your structure that time turn it into
we would have already created an object
that is represents the box version of
that but needs to put the data in and it
has a full back if it's not one of the
nice cases of the right sort of size
because it can't just do it via pointers
of unsigned 32 and so on um but it also
has to tell the garbage collector you've
if you know with struts you can actually
have a strut that has a reference and
this is when struts get complicated you
can have a strut that contains a field
that is a class right that's for you
know you can write code like that
so if it's then making a copy of that
then it has to tell the gc look hey i've
made another reference
to a object you need to know about that
because that's going to affect how you
do garbage collection right you need to
know there's now two references and only
when they both go can you clean it up
and all that sort of stuff so that's
what it's doing this is like the lowest
level
and even then it's doing some um you
know interesting stuff with pointers and
car oh gosh yeah don't you love c plus
plus although actually you can write
nowadays you can write c sharp code that
looks not too dissimilar with all the
new features they keep adding but
lets you write something more and more
like c sharp
it's also quite nice that basically it's
uh you know some of the code in the
runtime is readable even if you're not c
plus right we can all read a while loop
and stuff like that we can have a rough
idea of what's going on
uh unboxing is uh the reverse you don't
tend to unbox as much as your box really
it's normally a one-way thing but you
can unbox if you want to
and again there's some again the runtime
tries to do the best it can in all these
situations you probably shouldn't box
because it's i overhead
but you know if you're boxing then
you're gonna you probably shouldn't
unbox because it's even more overhead
but it still made it as quick as it can
across the runtime
another thing to think about with struts
is that
essentially um
when you pass a strut it's kind of like
so you have an instance method on a
strut it's kind of like you're passing
it with the ref keyword because when you
call an instance method on a strut
and it you know
changes the value of a field or whatever
you'd like it to operate on the
the the struct you called it on you
wouldn't like it to be on a copy right
because then you'd lose those values
so um
again uh runtime we don't care right
when we call a method on a an instance
method on a strut versus a class we're
not worrying about what's going on but
the runtime has to figure some of this
stuff out to make sure it does what we'd
expect
and another one to finish with on struts
so you have a structure you might
override two string right
think about what happens when you box
the struct there's a two string method
on object right so you would like your
two string method to be called not the
kind of standard one built in one on
object which basically prints the type
name right if you've ever seen that
but uh it gets a bit complicated so
as we talked about before a struct looks
like this in memory when it's boxed
you've got the extra stuff the method
table the object header and then the
data at the end is the same that's
basically how it does boxing in a
pictorial form
when you uh
have an object the this point of the
point of the object is actually to the
front of the method table
so it can then do that kind of look up
quite quickly
it could be behind a meta table but the
runtime chooses to be between the object
header and the method table
but essentially it means that by the
time you've called the my the tostring
method the pointer actually needs to be
here because that two-string method will
make assumptions about the layout i'll
destruct
so this is getting way into the weeds on
like struts but essentially uh even if
you're boxing struts the runtime and i
said stubs for everywhere there's a stub
that fixes up that pointer so it can
just so again you know if we ever meet
a.net runtime engineer this is stuff we
generally don't have to worry about we
should probably uh
thank them that we can just write code
in the most simple way
and it does the right thing and it does
it efficiently okay on to the last
section that i'm talking about today
tier compilation
people heard about this this has been
around for a little while in net core
um a few people yeah okay so uh it's
been in the runtime since 2.1 and they
turned it on by default since three i
think anyway certainly in dot net
five and six it's on by default
um and the basic idea behind it is um
that uh
the problem with uh just in time is it's
just entirely i mean the not necessary
problem but it's the nature of it but if
you have method a that calls method b
that calls method c that calls method d
they all need to get jitted before they
can run because it has it as it hits the
point in method a that it needs to jit
method b it goes and jits it and so on
so jitting can be a problem for startup
uh if you've ever used like engine and
things like that there is ways around
that you can pre-compile that so it
doesn't have to do that and certainly
the the base class libraries and the
runtime is shipped with that all done
because otherwise startup would be
really slow
um but our code generally isn't unless
we've made the step of doing engine
previously now ready r2 are ready to run
is the kind of precursor for that so you
can do that
and it obviously matters startup is
matters more in like a containerized
world right where or
azure functions those sorts of things
where you know we expect things to be
running quickly if it's a long running
process on a server maybe starting up in
five seconds versus two is not such a
problem if it's a function that takes
that you know a second to run then that
starts to become a problem so that this
whole startup is saying they worry about
um and
again another stub
so when the code and the way it works is
just in time is it puts the stub into
place and the first time you call a
method it hits that stub
and that stub's job is then to jit the
method and then rewrite the stub so that
next time you don't go through the stub
you go straight to the methods that's
what the stubs there
and so you see after jitting we've lost
the pre-stub
pre-code fix-up
has to still exist
for a bunch of scenarios and can also
help with things like
generics and other places where we
always need a stub
but there is a way to go straight to the
native code
so yeah the pre-stub is what's happening
the first time if you ever
and you can sometimes see this if you
debug code some of these things show up
in a stack trace
pre-stub
with tier compilation what they've done
is they've left some of that in so
they've left the pre-stub in but it's
now got a counter and the basic idea of
tier compilation is this is that
actually a lot of methods
don't need to be heavily optimized the
first time right if that method only
runs once
why spend relatively a long time in the
jits doing all these really impressive
optimizations if it's only going to
execute once but you know what if that
method is executed
10 000 times a second you'd really like
the most optimal version of that method
so what tier compilation does it breaks
that dependency says right the first end
times i believe it was 30 but anyway
there's a counter it can be a bit more
intelligent that but it says look we'll
do the quickest jits possible the first
time it's called minops minimum
optimizations don't try and do anything
fancy just get that code out there as
quickly as possible it's functional code
there's no doubt about that but it's not
the most optimized do that put a counter
in see how many times the method's
called if it becomes hot
on a background thread rejit the method
so it's not blocking execution and then
in quite a clever way switch it out
because you have to worry about if the
method's executing and there's a
synchronization thing going on there
once you've done that then switch out
for an optimized version
and that really helps start up time
because you can do the minimum work
first time and then worry about it later
and it also helps them do extra analysis
because they can actually i don't know
how much is simply implemented but the
idea is actually you can do a second
attempt and then maybe down the line you
could do a third and fourth term once
the mechanism is there there might be
stuff how you say look another type's
been loaded it changes our idea of how
the program's working let's have another
go optimising these methods so i believe
at the moment it's just tier zero and
tier one but there's you know theory the
mechanisms there for more
um and then um yeah with that optimized
one we now have um again and it still
keeps around so you've got the optimize
native code so this is after it's done
the tiered
tier one which is the more optimization
it's um now the method is gonna every
time it's going to be called it's gonna
go to the octopus one but it still keeps
the original one around and there's
various scenarios where they might want
to go back because actually there's a
potential that they made a uh a bad
decision right there's there's some
flexibility there and it also um relates
to things that i want to work on with
like the profiling api whether it's
ability to region methods and a bit of
stuff with sometimes when you're
debugging there's a way it can change
the optimization of methods there's a
few cases where it needs to go back and
forwards
and this is part of a larger
initiative
this is i think this is more of a design
document i've not seen
how much of this has yet been
implemented but the idea is that yeah
reach it there
the point is is that actually there
might be times where even we talked a
bit about generics you might see a
method a generic method you might want
to optimize the int version because you
see that being called loads but the
version for string
is not called so much you want to leave
that as is so yeah they can
the mechanism behind this is code
version it can allow more but at the
moment it's mostly
tier zero tier one
so that's uh that's it of a
brief introduction to the runtime and
performance um there's uh yeah booker
runtime is really a great place to start
i've uh written a bunch of blog posts
about internals but also some of like if
you want to find your own way through
this right so
resources how to explore the runtime
some tools and other presentations for
other people so there's some blog posts
to get started with but
thank you thank you